There are 2 types of people in Spain who have the right to fall and get up people
who have an economic mattress who have a family that can help them when they run
out of work can go to work at their father's company that is going to a house and
other types of people who have a precarious job who are the son or daughter of people
who have always had a precarious job and who have a precarious job.
the only thing they are going to in their house are debts,
those are the 2 types of people that exist in Spain and the people who belong to
the second type of people also have the right to fall and to get up and fall and
to have the right to fall down means taking the risk of setting up a business and
it is bad for you to choose a studio because you like them and not because
they are the ones with the most exits,
that is to have the right to fall down and to fall down.
to get up and that is why,
colleagues,
is this income guaranteed?